For many men, the question of whether I want to
make a move can feel like
walking a tightrope. Making a
move too soon can lead to
misinterpretation, while
waiting too long can lead to
missing the opportunity altogether.
Luckily, while every person is
different, there are common signs a
woman can show when she's open to
you taking the next step.
Whether it's starting a
deeper conversation, asking her
out, or attempting a kiss.  In this
video, we'll look at five signs a
woman wants you to make a move.
Before you begin, stop
settling for lukewarm relationships,
love bonds,
relationship psychology, conscious seduction,
authentic attraction and
personal growth is the book that reveals how to
ignite deep connections,
develop magnetic attraction and
fuel overwhelming personal growth
.  Link description.  number
one gives you his full attention.
In the complex and delicate game of
romantic connection, recognizing
when a woman wants you to make
a move can feel like deciphering a
subtle language of gestures, expressions,
and emotional cues.
One of the strongest signs that he might be
longing for a
deeper connection is when he
gives you his full attention.  In
a world filled with distractions, where
smartphones constantly vibrate and
daily obligations drag us in
every direction, undivided attention is a
rare and powerful form of interest.
When a woman chooses to put away
her phone and direct her entire
presence toward you, it's not just
politeness, it's intention.  He is
consciously choosing to be fully in the
moment with you.  His body language
often reflects this intention.   He
may lean slightly toward you,
maintain constant eye contact, and
respond attentively to your
words.  These signals create a space
where meaningful interaction can flourish
.  Their attention isn't
limited to listening, they
actively engage, perhaps asking
probing questions or showing genuine
curiosity about your thoughts and
experiences.
This kind of concentrated energy speaks
louder than words.  When a woman
makes you feel like you're the only
person in the room, it's often her
way of telling you that she's ready to see you
as more than just an
acquaintance.  Number two, it stays even
after the conversation should
be over.  In the world of
human interaction, much of
communication happens beyond words.
Subtle cues, pauses, and gestures often
mean more than what is
said.  One of the clearest,
yet most easily overlooked, signs that
a woman might want you to make a
move is when she sticks around even after
the conversation has naturally come
to an end.  This remaining is not
accidental.  As a conversation nears its
conclusion, most
people begin to distance themselves.
maybe he looks at his phone, changes
posture, or says a polite, "Well, I have to
go."  If, on the other hand, she resists these
signs of closure and remains present,
even though there is no need, she
is probably creating space for
something more to happen.  He may slow
his pace if you're walking, hesitate
before saying goodbye, or maintain
eye contact as if
waiting for you to say something to
prolong the moment.  This silence,
this pause, is often a gentle invitation
to take the next step, ask for her
number, suggest meeting up again, or say
something that makes the interaction more
personal.  Number three, suggests
future plans or leaves glimpses.  When trying
to figure out if a woman is interested in
taking things further, pay
attention to when she suggests
future activities or leaves open-ended sentences that
seem to invite you to participate.  If
he says something like we should do it
sometimes it's not a casual phrase, it's
a veiled invitation, a chance he
leaves you to take the initiative.
Sometimes she talks about an event or a place
without saying who she's going with, leaving
space for you to introduce yourself.  The way he
says it and the frequency with which he repeats it
are strong clues that he wants to
see you again.  Number 4, responds
positively to light flirting.  If
you notice him smiling, maintaining
eye contact, laughing at even your lightest jokes,
or playing physically with you, such as
lightly touching your arm, this is a
clear sign of openness.  Certain gestures
like leaning closer, touching her hair, or
mimicking your movements indicate that she is
comfortable and attracted.  The distance he
maintains, the tone of voice and the energy he
puts into the conversation are
valuable indicators.  Number five,
mention being single or available.
When a woman drops single phrases into the
conversation unprompted
, it's a powerful signal.  She might
mention that she's spending the weekend
alone or that she has no plans, or she might make
light-hearted comments about bad
dates or how
dating apps aren't working out.  The
timing of when you choose to reveal
this detail is important.  If he does it
in a more intimate context, after
laughing or sharing something personal, he
probably wants you to get the
message.  It's a subtle way of saying the
coast is clear if you want to come forward.
Stop Settling for
Lukewarm Relationships: Love Connections,
Relationship Psychology, Conscious Seduction,
Authentic Attraction, and
Personal Growth is the book that reveals how to
ignite deep connections,
develop magnetic attraction, and
fuel overwhelming personal growth
.  Link in description.